Scott Pilgrim vs. the World was
unleashed on the world in 2010,
thanks to director Edgar Wright. Based on the
graphic novels by Bryan Lee O'Malley, the film
developed a cult following due to its frenetic
action scenes, bizarre and endearing plot,
and its spectacular ensemble cast. Here's what
they've been up to since appearing in the film.
In the end, no other actor
could have played the mumbly,
self-effacing, insecure Scott Pilgrim as
perfectly as Michael Cera. At this point,
Cera had already made a name for himself
in popular comedies like Superbad and cult
television favorites like Arrested Development.
However, Scott Pilgrim also gave Cera a chance
to flex his action hero chops during the
sequences when he fights Ramona's evil exes.
"Mr. Lee!
You're needed back on set."
Since Scott Pilgrim, Cera has continued working
steadily, appearing in plenty of comedies like
This Is The End, as well as dramas
like Molly's Game and Gloria Bell.
Cera has also dabbled in voice work, lending his
vocal stylings to the 2021 animated film Cryptozoo
and taking on the role of Robin in The
Lego Batman Movie. On the small screen,
Cera has also been seen in shows like Wet
Hot American Summer: First Day of Camp,
the 2017 Twin Peaks revival — and
of course, the Netflix-produced
continuation of Arrested Development, where
he reprised his role as George Michael Bluth.
The role of the intimidatingly beautiful,
smart, and unflappably cool Ramona Flowers
could have been harder to relate to with
the wrong actor in the role, but luckily,
Mary Elizabeth Winstead was more than up to the
task when Edgar Wright tasked her with the part.
Ultimately, despite the colorful absurdity of the
plot, viewers can't help but understand why Scott
decides he has to risk his life fighting multiple
evil exes in order to win Ramona's heart. Are
these two a couple for the ages? Probably not, but
you'll probably end up rooting for them anyway.
Since appearing in Scott Pilgrim, Winstead has
kept busy, landing roles in a string of films
that included The Spectacular Now and Swiss
Army Man. She also had an excellent turn in
2016's 10 Cloverfield Lane. In more recent
years, Winstead has appeared in a season of
FX's anthology series Fargo and films like 2019's
Gemini Man. Circling back to superhero action,
Winstead also delivered a supporting turn
as Huntress in 2020's DC hit Birds of Prey.
"They call me… Huntress."
Scott Pilgrim vs. the World is packed to the
brim with funny characters, but as Scott's dry,
quick-witted roommate Wallace, Kieran Culkin
may just deliver the funniest performance in
the entire film. Wallace, who spends the film
making conquests out of several handsome men
and just generally supporting Scott, always
has the perfect thing to say at just the right
time, and it's impossible not to laugh at
Culkin's interpretation of the character.
Culkin has been acting since he was a kid, but
HBO subscribers and prestige television fans
definitely know him best for his supporting
role as the cocky Roman Roy on Succession,
the black comedy about a wealthy family and its
children all jockeying for their father's seat of
power at the head of the family mega-conglomerate.
Culkin earned Emmy nods two years in a row
for the role, proving that his delightful
performance as Roman is no flash in the pan.
As Scott continues his courtship of Ramona,
he's surprised to discover that he must defeat
her exes in order to earn the privilege
of dating her... and one of those exes
is an actual movie star. When Scott and
Ramona cross paths with her second ex,
Lucas Lee, played by Chris Evans, he's in the
midst of filming his newest blockbuster film,
but he still takes the time to
fight Scott for Ramona's affections.
"I used to date that clown." "Aaaaaand…" "ACTION!"
By the point Evans signed on to play
Lucas Lee in Scott Pilgrim vs. the World,
the actor was already a movie star in real
life. After his first comic book adaptation,
2007's Fantastic Four, Evans took on another
role from Marvel's comics that would eventually
come to define a truly blockbuster chapter in
his career: Steve Rogers, aka Captain America.
Evans debuted in the role just one year after
Scott Pilgrim, starring in 2011's Captain America:
The First Avenger and reprised it for two more
Captain America films and several Avengers
crossover movies before hanging up his shield
for good in 2019's Avengers: Endgame. Beyond
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, Evans has
also appeared in a handful of other roles,
including the critically beloved hit Knives Out,
showcasing that he's more than just an Avenger.
As Scott's sister Stacey, Anna Kendrick doesn't
have the biggest role in Scott Pilgrim vs. the
World, but it's a delight to see her every time
she pops up onscreen, whether she's scolding
Scott over his inappropriately aged girlfriend
or losing yet another boyfriend to Wallace's
charms. Stacey serves as one of a few female
characters that seem to make up a Greek chorus
that yells at Scott more or less nonstop,
but thanks to Kendrick's natural charm,
she makes Stacey a fully realized character
in a very short amount of screen time.
"Hey. Yeah, I know. Oh, it's sooooo pathetic."
Kendrick got even busier in the years
after Scott Pilgrim — by that point,
she already had an Academy Award nomination
for Up in the Air, and she followed her early
successes with critically acclaimed hits
like 50/50, Pitch Perfect and its sequels,
and Into the Woods. The actor has also lent her
voice to 2016's Trolls and its sequel, and she
became a published author the same year when she
released a memoir, titled Scrappy Little Nobody.
Long before the film begins, Scott has his
heart broken by his own evil ex, who also
plays in a band — albeit one that's much more
successful than his own. Played by Brie Larson,
the lead singer of the Clash at Demonhead,
Natalie "Envy" Adams has, according to Scott,
sold out and signed with a huge label. By
the time the film's narrative gets started,
Envy is an enormous star already. However, when
she and Scott reunite and it turns out that her
bassist/boyfriend is yet another ex of
Ramona's, the situation gets even stickier.
After appearing in indies like 2013's The
Spectacular Now and big blockbuster comedies
like Trainwreck, Larson achieved a huge career
milestone when she won an Oscar — as well as
several other major awards — for her leading
performance as a kidnapping victim with a
young son in the gripping 2015 drama Room. In the
aftermath of her Oscar win, Larson started picking
up blockbuster roles in films like 2017's Kong:
Skull Island, and in 2019, she made her debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as Carol Danvers,
also known as Captain Marvel. Beyond acting,
Larson has also stepped behind the camera;
in 2017, she made her directorial debut,
Unicorn Store, featuring her friend and
Captain Marvel co-star Samuel L. Jackson.
Scott's band, Sex Bob-omb, only has one
female member. It's easy to see that Kim Pine,
played by Alison Pill, definitely has
enough attitude and talent to balance
the band's scales. As Sex Bob-omb's drummer,
Kim is clearly still pretty bitter about an
obviously bad breakup between her and Scott.
Though she can't help herself from making snide
comments about Scott more or less constantly,
she still supports him and the band overall.
Pill has appeared in several films
since, like 2013's Snowpiercer,
but is mostly known for TV work.
She took on a starring role in
HBO's Aaron Sorkin drama The Newsroom as
network associate producer Maggie Jordan,
staying with the show throughout its run. In
recent years, Pill has shown up in projects
like American Horror Story: Cult and on CBS'
Star Trek: Picard, which began its run in 2020.
As the sarcastic, foul-mouthed Julie who
constantly pops up where Scott least expects
to see her, Aubrey Plaza is a perfect addition
to Scott Pilgrim. Julie is no fan of Scott's,
to be sure, but she has connections with
everyone in Toronto, which means Plaza
gets to pop up several times... with a black
bar typically obscuring her profane insults.
"I can't even believe I'm saying
this, but Envy Adams would like
you all to come backstage." "All
of us?" "Did I F------ stutter?"
Before she appeared in Scott Pilgrim, Plaza was
already a part of the ensemble cast of Parks and
Recreation. She played the sharp-tongued
and morbid April Ludgate — later April
Ludgate-Dwyer — until the series ended in
2015, at which point she joined FX's Legion.
Plaza also appears in several films, often playing
dark and quirky, such as in Ingrid Goes West. She
continued that run in 2020 with two high-profile
indies, Happiest Season and Black Bear.
Brandon Routh plays one of Ramona's evil
exes as well as Envy's new boyfriend,
Todd Ingram. He impacts Scott Pilgrim vs. the
World's story in multiple ways, but there's
one part of his identity that's more important
than anything else: he's a vegan. Thanks to his
special diet and ability to maintain it, Todd has
pretty intense powers. Envy even spells it out.
"Short answer: being vegan just makes
you better than most people." "Bingo."
Todd's false cloak of veganism is eventually
removed, but the casting of Routh, known for
playing one of the most famous superheroes
of all time, is likely no accident. By the
time he appeared as Todd, Routh had already
played Superman in 2006's Superman Returns,
though he was replaced in the franchise
reboot Man of Steel. Since Scott Pilgrim,
Routh has appeared in a number of projects,
including returning to his superhero roots on
the CW's Arrow and its sister shows as Ray "The
Atom" Palmer. He even got to reprise his role as
Superman on the CW in the Arrowverse crossover
Crisis on Infinite Earths from 2019 to 2020.
Scott handily defeats most of
Ramona's evil exes, but her final ex,
powerful music executive Gideon, played by
Jason Schwartzman, is a little bit harder to
crack. As soon as Ramona sees Gideon again, she
falls under his spell — which, as it turns out,
is thanks to a literal microchip Gideon
implanted in her neck — and though Scott
thinks he's lost her forever, he wages one final
boss fight against Gideon to win her freedom.
Schwartzman was already starring in HBO's
detective comedy Bored to Death by the time
he appeared in Scott Pilgrim vs. the World,
but viewers probably know him best from his
consistent collaborations with director Wes
Anderson - he's appeared in Moonrise Kingdom,
The Grand Budapest Hotel, and 2021's The
French Dispatch, to name a few. However,
he's also found time for non-Anderson
projects, including Saving Mr. Banks,
the 2014 drama Big Eyes, and the
2018 Netflix comedy Wine Country.
Throughout his battles with the first few
exes, Scott keeps calling them Ramona's
evil ex-boyfriends, and never seems to take notice
when Ramona corrects him by saying exes. However,
he soon figures out why; one of her exes, Roxy
Richter, definitely isn't a boyfriend at all, but
she definitely has a bone to pick with Scott. Roxy
is played by the always hilarious Mae Whitman.
"I was just a little bicurious."
"Well honey, I'm a little bi-furious!"
Scott Pilgrim vs. the World marks
the second project that found Cera
and Whitman sharing the screen —
earlier, they starred together as
George Michael Bluth and his unremarkable
girlfriend Ann on Arrested Development,
roles that continued throughout the original
series as well as its belated Netflix revival.
Though Whitman has appeared in movies like
2012's The Perks of Being a Wallflower and
2015's The DUFF, most of her work has been on
television: she's had several guest roles and
is one of the stars of NBC's crime comedy Good
Girls alongside Retta and Christina Hendricks.
At the start of Scott Pilgrim vs. the World, Scott
is utterly devoted to his role as the bassist
of Sex Bob-omb, but as he gets more involved
with Ramona and his battles against her exes,
he ends up shirking his responsibilities.
Enter Young Neil, played by Johnny Simmons,
the meek and soft-spoken roadie who
follows the band around; a bassist himself,
Neil knows all of Scott's parts, and ends up
filling in for him more or less permanently.
Simmons had already popped up in Diablo
Cody's horror comedy Jennifer's Body and
other recognizable films by the time he
appeared in Scott Pilgrim. In recent years,
Simmons has acted in movies like 21 Jump Street
and 2016's The Late Bloomer. He's also made guest
appearances on television series and had a regular
role on Netflix's short-lived series Girlboss.
Bill Hader might not physically appear in Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World, but if you listen carefully
during a scene between Scott and Ramona, you
can clearly hear his distinctive voice. When
Ramona mentions that Scott's hair is getting
shaggy, he notes that he got his last haircut
just a few hours before his bad breakup with
Envy; as he reminisces on their split, Hader's
voice contradicts him, clarifying that Scott was
brutally dumped, no matter what he tells Ramona.
"It was a mutual thing." "It wasn't." "I mean,
she told me it was mutual."
"She dumped him. It was brutal."
Hader was already a staple of Saturday Night
Live when he provided this cheeky voiceover,
albeit toward the end of his tenure. Though Hader
is best known for comedic roles in movies like
Trainwreck and Inside Out, the actor has taken
on more dramatic roles in recent years. In 2019,
he starred as an adult Richie in It: Chapter Two,
and beginning in 2018, he's played the title role
on HBO's Barry as an assassin turned actor,
which has earned him multiple Emmy Awards.
Every band needs a good-looking, guitar-playing
frontman, and in Sex Bob-omb, that frontman
is Stephen Stills, played by Mark Webber.
Desperate for a record deal, Stephen will do
just about anything to launch the band to stardom,
including betraying Scott to sign with Gideon.
After his turn as Stephen, Mark Webber showed
up in fare like For a Good Time, Call...,
Laggies and Happy Christmas. Webber also
does plenty of work behind the camera,
working on some of films in multiple capacities:
he wrote, directed, and starred in movies like
2014's The Ever After and 2017's Flesh and Blood.
At the beginning of Scott Pilgrim vs. the
World, Scott's friends berate him for dating
a much younger girl — specifically, a
high school student named Knives Chau,
played by Ellen Wong. Knives idolizes
Scott and can't believe her luck in
dating an older man. Well… man-child.
She is absolutely obsessed with Scott,
but as he starts to fall for Ramona, he pushes
Knives aside, inspiring her desire for revenge.
"I’m not talking to you! I'm talking to her!"
"What" "You broke the heart that
broke mine. Get ready to chow down!"
Wong's wide-eyed demeanor and her previous martial
arts training helped her land the role of Knives,
and after Scott Pilgrim, she continued
working steadily on the small screen.
Wong has appeared in several hit television shows,
including The Carrie Diaries and Dark Matter,
eventually landing a recurring role with
Netflix on their original series GLOW.
Wong played the role of Jenny, who
wrestles under the moniker Fortune Cookie.
Scott Pilgrim vs. the World is full of hilarious
supporting players, few of whom are quite as funny
as Michael Comeau, played by Nelson Franklin.
Comeau is absolutely everywhere, from the party
where Scott first meets Ramona to the Chaos
Theatre during Scott and Gideon's final battle,
and no matter where he is, he can be heard in the
background making some sort of obnoxious comment.
"You know, so I told them
you've got a really good sound,
and I think you should market
your sound to deaf people."
Franklin, tends to pop up in television and
film projects as a utilitarian comedic actor,
though television is where you've most likely
noticed him. He's appeared in recurring roles
on some of the best comedies of the last
several years, including The Office, Veep,
New Girl, and black-ish, and was a part of the
main cast on shows such as The Millers and Abby's.
Before Scott even learns about Ramona's seven
evil exes, he attends a Battle of the Bands with
Sex Bob-omb — with both Ramona and Knives in the
audience — and finds himself in a very different
kind of battle when Ramona's first ex, Matthew
Patel, played by Satya Bhabha, shows up and
performs a Bollywood-style song and dance number
about fighting Scott. Scott makes pretty quick
work of Matthew, but as a result of the fight,
Ramona is forced to explain the situation at hand.
The British-born Bhabha appeared in the
leading role in 2012's Midnight's Children,
based on the novel of the same name, and followed
that up with recurring roles in comedies like New
Girl and Eastsiders. More recently, from 2017 to
2018, Bhabha played the recurring role of Habib
in Netflix's original series Sense8, appearing
for five episodes throughout its second season.
Early on in Scott Pilgrim vs. the World, Sex
Bob-omb faces off against competitors in a
Battle of the Bands; unfortunately
for rival band Crash and the Boys,
Matthew Patel's arrival signals their doom.
Erik Knudsen plays leading man Crash and,
armed with their very own girl drummer — much
to Kim's chagrin, the band launches into their
hits. After they're incinterated, though,
Sex Bob-omb wins the competition by default.
A year after Scott Pilgrim, Knudsen showed up
in the 2011 horror sequel Scream 4. These days,
Knudsen is probably best known for
his recurring and leading roles in
shows like the dystopian Jericho and
the science fiction series Continuum.
Though it se19ems as if Todd Ingram's vegan
lifestyle will overpower Scott completely during
their fight over Ramona, Scott ultimately
defeats his rival with an unlikely weapon:
coffee with a splash of milk.
"What are you talking about?" "You
just drank half and half baby."
Almost immediately, the Vegan Police, played
by Thomas Jane and Clifton Collins Jr.,
show up to investigate. As it turns out,
Todd has been transgressing a lot lately,
enjoying everything from gelato to chicken
parmesan. After the Vegan Police revoke
Todd's vegan powers for his crimes, they
prance off, high-fiving exuberantly.
If you're a fan of HBO's original programming,
you might remember Jane from his series Hung,
which aired from 2009 to 2011, and
if you're into science fiction,
you've probably seen him recently in
a leading role on Syfy's The Expanse.
As for Collins Jr., he showed up in 2019's
Once Upon a Time... in Hollywood and the
Veronica Mars continuation that same year, and
Westworld fans will recognize him as Lawrence.
Wallace makes plenty of conquests during Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World, and as it happens,
one of them actually shares a
name with the movie's protagonist.
Since Wallace and the main Scott share a bed,
Lewis's character Other Scott ends up bonding
with his counterpart, privy to the personal
details of his life and pursuit of Ramona.
Lewis has had plenty of television guest
roles, including parts in Designated Survivor,
The Handmaid's Tale, and Suits. He typically
plays minor roles in both film and television,
but he did play a recurring role on
Arrow as the adult William Clayton.
As Scott approaches Gideon's
new venue, the Chaos Theater,
to fight Ramona's final evil ex for her
heart, he comes across an apparent obstacle:
the place seems pretty closely guarded at first
glance. However, when Scott actually interacts
with the security guards — played by John Patrick
Amedori and Joe Dinicol — anything from the word
"whatever" to just a grunt gets him into the
theater, and when Scott revisits the boss battle,
he vanquishes the guards entirely,
leaving piles of coins in his wake.
Outside of Scott Pilgrim, Amedori has
been in several huge television shows,
including a recurring role on the hit teen soap
Gossip Girl as one of Serena van der Woodsen's
love interests. Amedori also scored a leading role
as Gabe in 2017 on Netflix's Dear White People.
As for Dinicol, like so many other Scott Pilgrim
performers, he's known for a role on Arrow — in
his case, as Rory Regan, or Ragman — as well
as guest appearances on many other shows.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars and films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.